[Musique]
que c'est payet qui symbolise larmes de
change sa vie ses engagements son
histoire
mes chers amis je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver ici dans mon petit
appartement
alors je vous raconte tout agitateur
maoïste activiste homosexuel et drogué
non mais j'ai toujours été un déraciné
et rio j'ai pas pourquoi mais c'est moi
qui racontent aux personnes ne relis mes
disques ou et est donc que ce que je
raconte est vrai que je connais c'est le
genre de guêpier surtout j'avais aussi
connu le genre de aides
j'ai découvert celui du mouvement de
libération homosexuelle
j'ai découvert aussi celui de la
déportation et que ça a été
effectivement une rencontre très riche
j'essaie de me rappeler comment j'étais
rencontre et ben moi j'en sais rien moi
ce que je peux dire sur j'en sais que
j'ai jamais été d'accord avec lui
politiquement je ne suis pas dans un
double personnage je ne suis qu il aux
frênes que quand je m'amuse
non mais en même temps ça me faisait
peur quand même mais on n'avait pas peur
a choisi mon corps j'ai pas choisi
d'être là sur vos sexuelle mais je suis
furieuse l'image des homosexuels qui
rase les murs d'abord je suis un traître
ma classe me dit mais je savais pas qui
j'étais en paix je ne savais pas qu'ils
étaient meilleurs
il est pas évident que j'avais envie de
m'accepter
pourquoi elle génère le veer et ma
culpabilité je ne voyais pas pourquoi
j'aurais pas le droit d'exister faut
mettre de l'ordre dans le désordre fait
bordel de ma vie oui c'est vrai que je
ne connais pas en france deux personnes
qui étaient dans tous ses mouvements à
la fois aussi présenté aux six
engagements
on en parlera dans le film je vais bien
compris que j'étais un ennemi la
bourgeoisie et je m'exprimerai un jour
[Musique]
je vais rien à faire j'étais en prison
mon père militaire les horaires étaient
là tout était même le repas du vendredi
du jeudi du sein dit de la bonne le
chauffeur tout était réglé comme dans
une caserne dans un bateau de la marine
nationale
je n'avais rien d'autre à faire être le
gentil garçon objets objet fétiche de la
bourgeoisie on m'avait préparé une très
très bonne carrière de lycées de
facultés et c'est au conservatoire
j'étais un bon pianiste j'étais beau
gosse on n'avait plus qu'à me présenter
deux trois jeunes filles de la
bourgeoisie bordelaise un rôle à mon
destin de mon destin était tracé dans ce
qui commençait à être une haine de mon
père je crois que j'ai été au board de
grosses bêtises
puisque mon père
dans son bureau avec fin d'événement il
était il était symbole de l'or il était
le symbole surtout douloureux d'une
absence de tendresse il était le symbole
de l'absence il était le symbole de
[Musique]
pas d' une hétérosexualité triomphante
mais je voyais très bien que le chemin
serait ardue pour pouvoir dire que
j'étais homosexuel et pour pouvoir faire
que ils l'acceptent et je croyais le
chemin beaucoup plus difficile que ça et
en fait ça s'est mieux passé avec lui
qu'avec ma mère parce que c'était la n 2
mois c'est à dire que moi j'étais trop
que jamais il y avait pas ma place avec
mes convictions
donc il fallait que je disparaisse donc
j'ai vraiment pensé au suicide
quand les jeunes lesbiennes ou le jaune
idées et se découvre au mot souvent à
l'adolescence ils sont évidemment
vulnérables enfants et ados mais
d'autant plus vulnérable parce que
doublement vulnérables pouce à leur
famille ou sa de la société et donc ce
n'est ni dans l'oeil dans notre milieu
qui pourront trouver des soutiens moraux
et sociaux
et puis je commençais à devenir plutôt
singulier parce que je ne parlais à
personne donc un délire solitaire amène
assez vite
quelque chose de psychotiques et mon
père un jour m'a écrit qu'ils ne
décèdent et la cia presque trois ans il
m'a dit quand il était tout petit tu
étais complètement colérique ont-elles
dit dis maman et je disais non dit papa
et je disais non
et donc mes parents m'ont eu beaucoup de
fil à retordre avec ma petite personne
je me suis ennuyée dans mon adolescence
mais j'ai pas perdu mon temps j'étais
enfermé je savais pas où fugue et
j'avais envie de lui les me savais pas
où fugue mais en attendant je crois que
j'ai lu la moitié de la littérature
française qui m'a été un bagage quand je
sortirai dans la liberté est ce que j'ai
fait à 22 ans
bon j'aurais un bagage pour comprendre
les relations humaines même si je vais
passer une adolescence entière me parler
à personne
au lycée enfin quelqu'un s'approche de
moi qui n'étais en philosophie j'avais
18 ans et j'étais premier en philosophie
et ce jeune homme s'approche de moi une
habitude qui toi tu parle à personne en
rien un jour je suis d'accord d'aller
prendre un café avec lui et là il me
raconte sa vie qui est le site ressemble
à la mienne qui s'appelle charles ce
jeune homme
vingt ans après je le reverrai il
reconnaîtra que il était amoureux de moi
mais qu' ils n'osaient pas toujours ceux
ce discret 10 cet aspect péjoratif que
l'homosexualité peut trimballer et là
tout d'un coup très spontanément surtout
après la déception amoureuse pris la
plume et je me suis mis à écrire je me
promène dans la bibliothèque de mon père
c'est dans les biotech un peu sinistre
je trouve effectivement la culture la
littérature habituel en veut dire
officiel j'ai lu qu'elle est et les
intrigues cheval ça que j'ai lu qu'elle
était le lait et les cris de la pauvreté
jeunes sont larges et sur comment
fonctionner cet univers qui était très
loin de moi que je n'avais pas encore
éprouvé je suis absolument fasciné par
simone de beauvoir je trouve à un genre
bré
je vis la même chose donc je lui écris
et elle ne répond une très jolie lettre
j'étais absolument fou de joie
c'est à dire que entre la sacralisation
d'un livre et la personne derrière qui
prend le temps de vous répondre pour moi
j'étais absolument illuminait jusqu'au
bout de ma vie j'ai fait un concert en 3
mai 68 avec d'autres pianistes au grand
théâtre de bordeaux et le 8 mai 68
jean va hisser avec les étudiantes de
bordeaux le même grand théâtre où
j'avais joué quelques jours auparavant
donc là tout d'un coup quelque chose
basculer formidablement et je pars avec
une grande tristesse parce que je sais
que je
j'abandonne tous là
mes amours mais meurtri mon adolescence
et qu' il faut que je me démerde de tous
alors seul avec dédé des détails
complètement loufoque soeur je ne sais
même pas la courneuve
je ne sais pas repasser une chemise je
sais pas faire une lessive je ne sais
rien faire
tout d'un coup je passe de la grisaille
bordelaise avec sa flotté et seigneur
nous je voulais me jeter du pont de
pierre à lacoste à la baie des anges
nghia cette époque 21 ans je puis vous
dire que je ne l'avais jamais serrer
dans mes bras
quiconque et je ne pense pas que je
souffrais des émotions que pucelage mais
c'était quand même une double peine pour
moi et et là commence à un grand moment
de liberté de délire de nouvelles amies
un soir je vais dans je rentre dans le
jardin albert 1er
et je me dis là coco tu bouges pas ce
que tu as osé arriver jusque-là est
battu tu prends le premier détail qui
dit que tu croises dans les allées de ce
jardin et je vois tout d'un coup un
jeune homme qui avait des chaussures
jaunes sur notre qu'il avait acheté sa
d'italie hors de prix à milan puis j'ai
oublié de demander la marque et j'ai
suivi les godasses on est sorti du
jardin il me dira autonomie j'ai dit ok
tous vont se retrouver pour plus marre
et je me suis aperçu que non seulement
je n'avais pas joué mais que lui
il m'avait [__] trois fois ce qui
fait un baptême du feu à ces arv
[Rires]
j'étais content je suis très heureux que
j'aime pas besoin de lester projet riz
thé mais je suis très heureux d'avoir
rencontré par les fantômes de moi même
et des autres moi même dans une espèce
de d'identité
pluriel centre vous sans prendre le
risque que j'ai pu prendre un certain
moment de devenir compétences je suis
pour le support identité collective mais
mai 68 c'était une identité collective
68 ça a été un immense cri du genre de
vol 2
la révolution en marche promise par les
meneurs du quartier latin fenêtre pour
la première fois dans la communauté
homosexuelle l'espoir celui de sortir de
la clandestinité
celui de ne plus être montrée du doigt
dans tous les cris de cette jeunesse je
pensais vous pensez que j'aurais ma
place des chanteurs sur les
différentiels
oui
le phare en 71 ou là on commence
vraiment une sorte de militantisme gay
on entend quelque chose de nous on
attend il faut pas rêver les murs il
faut pas avoir honte d'être homosexuel
vous pensez que tous les [__] sont des
[__]
se prostituent
pourquoi il le ferait alors vivre sa
sexualité ouvertement
nous on n'en est pas mais il ya 71 des
mouvements monsieur soignants 75 comme
les autres en révolte vis-à-vis d'une
société puis de même d'une situation de
famille aux isles ott ne prenons pas les
homosexuels français décident de passer
à leur tour à l'action jean le bitoux
est l'un d'entre eux avec ses camarades
il fonde en 1971 à l'école des
beaux-arts le phare le front homosexuel
d'action révolutionnaire donc il ya une
génération justement la génération dgl h
groupe de libération homosexuelle
ça veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya une répression s'est libérée
c'est qu'il ya une oppression
il ya deux sortes de maux section il ya
d'abord ceux qui sont malades qui ce qui
concerne pour de l'argent alors c'est le
jargon juridique on parlait pas de mou
faut bien à l'époque c'était s'allonge
et donc des gens comme genre était très
important dans cette histoire
notre discours était extrêmement
politique et évidemment faisait fuir
les bourgeois homosexuels néanmoins il
nous fallait indiquer que nous avions un
aspect querelles moi j'ai toujours
respecté les gens du phare les gens du
gel h les jours du cul art parce que les
avais été là pour vraiment affronter des
problèmes graves qu'il fallait affronter
pour aider la condition des homosexuels
et donc on voulait et moi on était
porté par des idées nouvelles bien sûr
les idées situationniste avec raul van
tieghem traitait du savoir-vivre à
l'égard des jeunes générations et de
porc avec la société du spectacle on se
récite toujours les plus belles roses
des situationnistes et nous sommes
toujours convaincus que nous sommes dans
une société qu'ils avaient prévu dès
1965 avant 68 que ça serait une société
de consommation et d'une société de la
vitesse de la communication au moment
même où on n'a plus grand chose à se
dire intermédiaires se sont mis entre
les gens alors qu'il prétendait
faciliter la communication aujourd'hui
elle est mondiale mais il n'y a jamais
eu autant de guerres fratricides donc
c'est nécessaire au détriment du
voisinage et ça c'est extrêmement
cruelle et nous on était dans une
société qui était vraiment vieille avec
une jeune génération à qui on enseigner
un peu de trois petites choses
qu'est ce que c'est cette société de
consommation qui n'a qu'une obsession
c'est circulez circulez ya rien à voir
et les gens bougent mais les gens ne se
rencontrent pas je vais communauté en
communauté
ça veut dire aussi que je ne sais
absolument pas si je veux
rencontrez quelqu'un tous les gens
arrivent avec leurs névroses sur machin
y avait des haïtiens y avait malfrats
qui étaient qui s'était évadé de la
prison qu'on hébergées et saas est
dégradée parce que vous ferez mesure
club
le militantisme s'épuiser nous
concernant que les flics n'arrêtait pas
de nous surveiller et que ces petits
luxes terre commençait foutent vraiment
la poisse rome je suis absolument
hostile à la notion de couple
je trouve que c'est une une photocopie
de la petite bourgeoisie c'est le
mensonge c'est l'hypocrisie c'est la
double vie c'est le camouflage et tu
camoufle jusqu'au gens proches et plus
proche de toi c'est à dire je me serais
mariée oui oui et alors et j'aurais fait
des enfants mais ses enfants il répond
c'est quoi de moi et ma femme elle ne
serait pas senti trahi et je pense que
quand on commence à se cacher on fait
des dégâts en fins
donc le combat contre l'homophobie il
lit très très très loin d'être acquis et
il a fallu des gens comme ça dans les
années 70 pour le lancer est bien le
lanceur nous avons mis en place des 77
avec la la protection de frédéric
mitterrand un festival de films à
l'olympic entrepôts ou en janvier 78 on
voulait frapper fort on n'était plus
dans le 14e arrondissement on était
derrière le jardin de matignon de
monsieur le premier ministre hier il y a
un magnifique cinéma qui est une
ancienne pagode l'extrême droite ne
supporte pas cela le pouvoir giscardien
est très nerveux ils sont persuadés
qu'ils vont perdre les élections
législatives et donc tous les coups sont
permis
donc l'extrême droite jeune nation
attaque
le festival de la pagode
ils arrivent avec des matraques epeat la
caisse et qui rentre dans la pièce
obscure avec des poches d'encre rouge et
il les jette et le temps que la lumière
soit rétabli
dans le dans la salle obscure
tout d'un coup les gens sont persuadés
qu'ils sont pleins de sang ce sont des
méthodes nazies
thaci et
c'est dans ce cadre là avec guy
hocquenghem puis nous nous sommes dit il
faut aller plus loin que le culturel il
faut aller plus loin que la vie des
communautés il faut aller plus loin que
contester la vie nocturne gay il faut
demander une réforme du code pénal
français et il y a dans le code pénal
français à l'époque il y avait l'article
331 qui était très discriminant sur les
homosexuels et qui avait été mis en
place par le maréchal pétain en 1942
voilà mais on n'a pas été élu député de
france puisqu'on n'avait même pas de
quoi fabriquer des bulletins c'était
uniquement situationniste c'était
uniquement pour le geste pour alerter
les politiques qui avait oublié une
vieillerie de 1942 dans le code pénal
et après il faut il faudra simplement
attendre tranquillement 3 ans l'arrivée
de françois mitterrand pour que en
france
cette loi et il l'avait promis dans
cette campagne soit abrogée les
élections n'ont servi qu'à ça et dire il
y avait un compte à mixer telles copies
dont dessinateur grand homme de théâtre
qui nous avait fait la fiche
j'avais rédigé les petites bulles de la
dame assise mais elle a été placardée
dans tout paris
dans les arrondissements pour les
options candidats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est donc ici aux 188 boulevard
voltaire que une tribu s'est installée
on était cinq actions de changer la
culture gay où le militantisme gay il
faut créer de métier il faut créer des
journalistes il faut créer des revues
qui puisse expliquer ce qu'on est
je commence à comprendre comment
fonctionne un journal et là je vais voir
gérard broc avec qui j'avais eu une
liaison avant et qui est un comptable
avéré qu'ils étaient un comptable avéré
je lui dis voilà écoute moi je m'occupe
des journaliers c'est top tu t'occupes
de la structure s'il te plaît est ce qu
on peut être d'accord là dessus et me
dit oui le plus ancien le guêpier tir à
quarante cinq mille exemplaires
fondée par gérard vappereau et jean le
bitoux il fonctionne avec 25 permanents
qui se veulent bien sûr militants mais
avant tout journaliste
les pieds c'est l'histoire d'un nouveau
journalisme dans le sens où en 78 ans
avant les homosexuels ont subi une
censure trois semaines avant les
élections législatives
monsieur le président de la république
giscard d'estaing a décidé d'en finir
avec une presse différente qui avaient
le droit d'exister et qui a été
sauvagement interdite
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les choses ont
changé que ça sera beaucoup plus
difficile d'interdire une pression
sexuelle et surtout quand c'est une
presse qui n'est pas pornographique
quand en 1978 en juillet 70 j'ai
l'occasion de rencontrer michel concours
par l'intermédiaire de pierre de segovia
et du goupe b d'amsterdam
je le rencontre rue de vaugirard dans un
grand appartement et je lui indique que
j'ai un projet de presse gay je lui
propose de qu'il a pas eu de titre et il
me propose des piles et je dis mais
pourquoi et donc c'est dans l'éditorial
du numéro zéro pour pour être gay et
pour le pied et pour échapper au gai
pied des ghettos je crois que j'ai quand
même été un média vraiment très
important pour tout le monde
le but pour la société en général un
journal ça donne une audience beaucoup
plus large qu'un tract un journal
si on a des lecteurs potentiels on peut
y arriver ce que je voulais absolument
pas faire un journal parisien
c'était le journal de cette communauté
homosexuelle éparpillés et plus on est
loin de paris plus on s'offre une guêpe
il me manque et tout de suite dans le
journal qu'il sent très bien qu'une
solidarité existe depuis je crois que tu
as plus
entreprises les en termes de masse
salariale de journalistes de deux
employées en france etc les lecteurs qui
ont fait le journal c'est l'électeur qui
prenait le courage et nous voulons
aujourd'hui ils me disent encore le
grand frisson d'un jeune homme de 18 ans
et c'est comme le baptême du fossé
d'elle c'est d'aller jusqu'au kiosque et
de demander guêpier c'est comme un come
out and honey le guêpier et sutout à ses
origines et pendant plusieurs années
vraiment beaucoup plus proche de la
réalité laly des gays que d'écrire ne
pouvait pas vous pouvez plus être
interdit ce qui était quand même ma
grande hantise
il fallait pour cela que je m'appuie
aussi sur des intellectuels de renault
il avait entendu parler d'eux les
élections avec guy hocquenghem et
pendant l' attaque de la pagode il y a
eu une pétition absolument incroyable
signé simone de beauvoir marguerite
duras philippe sollers jean paul sartre
ils étaient tous là donc on avait déjà
fait le plein et il suffisait anthony
mais de le capitaine et qui n'est pas
dissociable de ses lecteurs c'est eux et
quand on a eu plusieurs problèmes
d'argent on a fait appel à eux et ils
souscrivent petites annonces briser
toutes les solitudes
c'était d'abord ça qu'il était aussi
pour nous important
je lisais beaucoup guêpier à l'époque
quand j'étais à paris je lâche des tous
les mois et qu'après toutes les semaines
quand j'arrive à paris à 17 ans en 91
j'apprends que dans la voiture du
guêpier il ya quelqu un en particulier
qui émergent et c'est jean le bitoux n'y
a pas d'identité
par contre il ya une culture et une
culture c'est à dire comment on
s'organise c'est par cette société n'est
pas du tout fait pour que deux garçons
décident de pas de faire l'amour parce
que ça tombe ça passe mais est un projet
de vie et un projet d'amour ça s'inscrit
ou dans cette société qui n'a absolument
pas l'intention d'accepter ce genre de
de transversalité comme quand je dis que
c'est une fille de mythologie que c'est
réellement mythologiques
c'est à partir du moment où il ya des
gens comme foucault qui traîne et puis
d'autres personnes et vie navarre et
tout ça on rentre là dans quelque chose
qui très prestigieux
cette solidarité michel ne s'est jamais
démentie et elle a permis à épier de ne
pas être interdits en interdit pas
foucault quand sartre faisait chier de
gaulle le miz l'intérieur 8v nommé dit
faudrait arrêter ça et là il nous énerve
avec la guerre au vietnam etc et de
gaulle a répondu en reprenant bastings
pas voltaire
il faut que je pense que c'était sa
grande interview qui me donne en juillet
78 il est pour le premier numéro de
guêpier on en parlait souvent ils me
disaient oui j'ai des choses à dire sur
l'homosexualité mais non je ne veux pas
être obligé de faire un beau come out
quand le journal du pied a eu un an je
voulais marquer ça de très grandes
signatures donc après coup qu'il lui
réunir au sein je voulais un interview
de jean paul sartre et donc j'ai écrit à
simone en lui disant voilà je voudrais
une interview sur la question sexuelle
pour être acteur
et voilà il me téléphone noir ou deux
elle me dit bon j'avais du jus jamais la
dre genou merci beaucoup
voilà j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui était
très affaibli il allait décider trois
malfaiteurs et d'exposer une étape
je suis allé avec de gilbert de dettes
et de bauchi et il a répondu d'une façon
extrêmement lucide et cet intérieur du
tour du monde leo franco brésilienne
internationale tous ont été ravis qu
enfin c'était la première interview sur
la sexualité
[Musique]
il a fallu des décennies pour que l'on
reconnaisse ici et là-bas la déportation
homosexuelle les tortures et ce qui
s'est passé il y a eu entre 100 et 150
mille homosexuels qui ont été arrêtés
soixante mille en allemagne qui ressent
parti en prison entre dix et quinze
mille qui se sont retrouvés dans les
camps de concentration
[Musique]
dès juillet 40 vichy avait commencé à
promulguer lois et décrets et nick le
statut des juifs interdiction de la
franc-maçonnerie internement des
étrangers des communistes et en 42 le
décret mettant l'homosexualité or la
loire
l'histoire c'est toute l'histoire la
mémoire c'est toute la mémoire quand on
oublie un déporté on oublie tout la
déportation tous les livres d'histoire
doivent être complétés par les horreurs
que l'on sait désormais aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je
cette mémoire doit être absolument
inscrite dans l'histoire de france
il y a eu des avancées grâce à monsieur
jospin et récemment grâce à monsieur
chirac en 2005 cette déportation à
exister en france on doit absolument la
reconnaître et la reconnaître aussi dans
les livres d'histoire et faire que
certaines fédérations de déportés cesse
de nous dire que ça n'a pas existé
puisque pierce elle était la preuve que
ça existait au moment où des amours sont
arrivés dans les régions reculées
ils se sont emparés les différents fifi
un paon particuliers affiche homosexuels
également les autres
[Musique]
notamment je peux parler des tortures nu
au milieu des différents traitements et
il essaie que pendre le condamné qui
était mort de les aider pendant deux
trois quatre jours et des cowboys
monnaie au 6e jeu j'ai été dans le
commando qui a construit deux pour un
emploi ça me nous avons bien vu ce qui
se passe et ce qui se tramait et nous en
bien groupe big wall street en serait
encore plus plus terrible que quand nous
étions
[Musique]
les tortures la croix gammée sur la tête
le mon ami manger vivant par les chiens
des natives et de la gestapo il a été
déshabillé un assaut sur la tête
on lui a lancé les chiens sur lui devant
nous dans il y avait donc des centaines
de personnes qui ont dû simple presque
chaque nuit je me réveille encore en
hurlant depuis près de 50 ans cette
semaine reste présente devant mes yeux
dans ma tête
jamais je n'oublierai cet assassinat
barbare de mon amour pourquoi ces tests
ils tous aujourd'hui sont ils donc tous
morts mais pour certains se taire est
peut-être la seule façon d'oublier mois
après des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années de silence
j'ai décidé de parler le témoigner
d'accuser je crois que les déportés ou
massacrés des portes et les autres ne
font pas bon ménage ensemble pourquoi
qui avait un litige qui est malheureux
c'est cette classification entre
un peu différent des portes et c'est à
dire les uns parce qu'ils sont peut-être
plus patriote parce qu'ils étaient
résistants ou anciens combattants et
tous les autres cdd frais
[Musique]
il s'est battu 20 ans pour que cette
cette vérité soit vraiment inscrits dans
le coeur même de l'histoire de france et
pour nous homosexuel c'est le premier
morceau d'une histoire qui enfin
apparaît et que nous protègerons le plus
longtemps possible malgré tout les bruit
et la fureur de l'histoire mémoire est
importante il faut qu'elle soit dans les
livres d'histoire et que les livres
d'histoire ne laisse pas de côté une
partie de la société
[Musique]
et
vous savez la chasse l'homosexuel cela
existe et je ne suis pas sûr que dans
certains cas cela ne perdure pas
[Musique]
bonjour direct ne l'a guère à être paris
2008 un tiers de siècle que cette marque
traverse paris un tiers de siècle de l
âme a été attaqué par l'extrême droite
compass
[Musique]
depuis quand ce n'est pas une farce il
croit que j'ai de leurs illusions
françaises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans 80 autres c'est 1000 personnes en
94 vingt mille personnes
84 60 mille personnes en 96 cent mille
personnes
et 97 300 me
aujourd'hui c'est 500 me c'est une
victoire pour la différence c'est une
victoire pour dire qu'il ya des gens qui
sont différents des autres
[Applaudissements]
pour la gay pride dont je suis un des
fondateurs j'ai tenu absolument à ce
qu'il y ait une minute de silence à la
fin de ces grand cortège exubérant
cela a été obtenu et cela continue à
fonctionner et j'en suis très heureux
mais qui prime c'est pas les homosexuels
c'est tous leurs amis leurs enfants
leurs parents leurs voisins qui sont là
qui applaudissent et qu'est-ce qu'ils
applaudissent
il s'est dit fier des joueurs
c'est comme ça qu'on gagne et c'est pas
la tolérance et de l'intégration ofii et
le gros problème c'est pas de ma
sexualité c'est l'homophobie s'est fait
fondamental d'expliquer comment des gens
issus du radicalisme des années 80
dirige la vie prague pour justement
passer d'une génération à l'autre
[Musique]
c'est le carnaval de paris devenue grave
erreur c'était quand c'était 1934 il a
été interdit parce qu'à l'époque sam
droit voulait prendre la semaine
nationale
dassault parce qu'ils aimaient beaucoup
est clair qu'il y avait plus aucun mur
de rammstein et donc n 33 et 34 des
maîtres est très dangereuse au l'extrême
droite a failli faire un coup d'état
public a interdit les manifestations
parce qu'elles pouvaient dégénérer
dedans que quand même un parmi plein de
bal musette et a été interdit
c'est comme au jour des fours du 16 et
comme les grandes fêtes du moyen-age on
se manque celio la gay pride était
devenu le contraire d'une manifestation
c'est une c'est une non pride puisque
tout le monde est fier d'être là et tout
le monde est joyeux d'être là et du zou
ligne et tu as raison que ça commence à
ressembler à la foire du trône
mais c'est une idée d'une image qui est
aujourd'hui hystériser exalté alors que
les premières des pride est la première
en 62 7 était un enjeu purement
politique extrêmement dangereux ont
pourchassé les photographes c'est pour
ça qu'il ya très peu de photos de toutes
ces années là parce qu'on était déjà
fiché qu'on avait à peine eu le temps de
dire un mot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il faut absolument que cette communauté
soit complètement solidaire il y a des
gay pride dans le monde ils sont
massacrés par la police comme un
beyrouth comme un mot ce qu il faut
absolument que la liberté de l'amour
[Musique]
en revanche je crois que le sida x y ou
les j'emploie ce mot là cette année au
logis du n'est pas très beau mais je
n'en connais pas d'autre
celui là il faut bien le dire est
contagieux par sa transpiration ses
larmes ça salit de peine son compte tard
ici je suis un espèce de l'épreuve qui
exigeait des celui là je souhaiterais
qu'il soit dans un centre avec un
personnel spécialisé d'accord avec des
règles d'hygiène strictes entre 85 et 95
des trois quarts de mes amis sont
décédées de cette maladie affreuse
je me suis impliqué longtemps
l'association aides pour travailler sur
la prévention gay j'ai aussi encouragé
beaucoup de mes amis à faire de la
prévention sida a témoigné à la
télévision su que j'étais moi même dans
une émission de closet parce que je
pensais que ce drame ne pouvait pas être
un drame privé
c'est un drame au collectif les débuts
de l'information sur le sida était
surtout basé sur des rumeurs sur des
possibles sur des informations médicales
qui était pas du tout vérifié par part
par une catastrophe vraiment médical des
années d'insouciance
vont s'arrêter au milieu des années 80
avec l'épidémie de sida les homosexuels
qui trouvaient que la vie finalement été
douce se retrouve à venir ici souvent au
père lachaise enterré leurs amis ce qui
permet quand même une mobilisation
au-delà de la souffrance et les
associations de lutte contre le sida
commence à s'installer véritablement à
partir de 85 que ce soir 4 sida aides ou
sida info service seul coup comme mon
ami est décédé à 58 ans du sida d'une
septicémie gravissime et qu'elle
violente qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
d'autant plus fier et à l'époque il n'y
avait pas les moyens de le sauver ce
grand philosophe 30 et il est mort du
sida en un an sachant à peine peu énervé
qu'il avait attrapé le sida une époque
on ne savait pas très bien ce qui était
en train de se passer
tout fatigué quitté que le sida c'était
une maladie en fait qui est il et le
clame été créé pour empêcher les abus
sexuels de garder leur sexualité c'est
vraiment quelque chose que beaucoup de
gens ont cru et d'après les dates moi
même j'étais déjà contaminé sans savoir
safran j'ai regardé des photos ya 3 août
et si vous n'en parlez aussi vous le
trio concernant beaucoup de créateurs
atteints par le sida que comme leurs
cornes étaient devenus curieux de
douleur il n'avait plus qu'à faire
quelque chose c'était de s'occuper de
leur culture leur corps n'avait plus
qu'à terminer des livres n'avait plus
qu'à terminer des peintures et des
chorégraphies et ça je pense que le
corps disparaît quand la maladie est
trop douloureux ya le témoignage de jean
paul aron la fin de sa vie très très
malade qui dit j'en ai assez j'en ai
[Musique]
et je jouerai je sais pas très bien
comment je me sentirai mais j'ai
toujours l'espoir
je ne suis pas défaitiste ce que je sais
c'est que quand il ya le feu on cherche
le willow où elle s'auto donc là je
viens de passer deux semaines à respirer
les odeurs des hôpitaux et à regarder
des bilans et des pronostics assez
inquiétant malgré le sourire embarrassé
de mes médecins que je me trouvais avec
14 6 me ou 1 je suis absolument pas sûr
je sais pas ce qu'il va me tuer si c'est
pas la chimie où il est et je pense que
là je dois absolument prendre en charge
cette conscience je me suis je suis
quelqu'un qui ne panique pas et je pense
avoir à peu près organiser ma vie pour
faire que quand on m'annonce des choses
catastrophiques je puis je puisse me
dire que quand même j'ai un peu prévu
cela et comme cela fait plus de 26 ans
que j'ai le sida je crois bien avoir
beaucoup réfléchi et je me dis score ce
corps détruits ce corps abîmés ou je
passe beaucoup de trop de temps dans les
cliniques et les hôpitaux je suis à ses
côtés
je sais qu'il est très abîmée peut-être
que c'est un peu de ma faute
certains moments mais ce corps doit
m'accompagner et je doit l'accompagner
pour terminer ce que nous avons à faire
mais nous ne jouiront plus
[Musique]
à
ils ont disparu philippe bérot fabrice
est maire
klaus nomi
gamarde
michel foucault marc collat mai
[Musique]
juncker
jean-paul araud
copie
hervé guibert qu'antoine pergaud
cecilio
david girat incarne al
mathieu gallet
ala emmanuel dreuil alain le roy
françois-xavier bndes et jorge donn jean
pierre miralles
eblé nero eric legris vincent legré
michel politis
jean blanc car vous risquerez marque
bedat jean marie koltès
[Musique]
on
le
beau
[Musique]
oh
jean de monts n'a pu avoir beaucoup de
conflits ou alors de mesures mais il n'a
jamais été question d'une sorte de
remise en question de sa place très
importante dans la création d'un
mouvement gay en france à un moment où
il fallait faire et où c'était beaucoup
plus dur de faire quoi que ce soit au
début des années 70 au milieu des années
70 au début des années 80 que maintenant
j'en fais partie de ces personnes qui
ont eu la clairvoyance véritablement
d'aplats cette libération il faut jamais
oublier que il ya des gens comme jean
qui qui ont battu pour qu'on est
certaine liberté
les libertés qu'on gagne on peut aussi
perdre
hommage à jeanne et du tout l'ami
intégral
mon frère une fatalité mpla câble s'est
abattue sur nous
ces gens ont du 21 avril 2010 à savoir
la désolation et l'effort
d'importants à jamais notre affection
l'ami intégral la pierre angulaire
j'allais vite ou à qui je rends ici et
moi je vibre en bien
monsieur ibrahima thiam dit là dessus
aujourd'hui c'est l'artiste que vous
parle
je suis triste on appelle aux yeux de
dépassement ensemble et on continue à
lutter ensemble présente moi je n'ai
jamais vu la mer mais la bannière
ensemble et voilà on ira voir le sur
l'océan
c'est la vie il faut accepter
l'inacceptable c'est comme c'est comme
un père les rapports avec votre fils et
père c'est très important
moi j'ai pas eu de père mais je pense
que les gens étaient vraiment mon père
ça a été mon amant et ça restera
toujours l'amour un des blessés toute la
vie déjà a été une quête éperdue de
l'amitié du don de soi de l'excellence
en somme la quête du plus est qui a
rayonné autour de lui dans son entourage
et bien ces activités coup sa
contribution lumineuse valais c'est
désormais un grand vide
une rumeur c'est un mec l'ena pour
saluer jean le bitoux le combattant le
guéry
l'infatigable mon ami mon père
[Musique]
ouais
on
mais
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
ok
je
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
on